Stay right in the middle of a run a second.
I'm all. VPN.
[Inaudible].
What's poppin. Welcome to my new crib like that.
I just bought up my Bitcoins.
So what we're doing is we're doing work from home Fridays.
I can't speak too loudly right now because you know,
most of the people are sleeping. It's actually 7:00 AM now,
but you know me and it's all about the grind. So I woke up pretty early. I got,
I'm gonna call my videos and stuff like that, but, uh, yeah. All right.
Let me just give you a tour. As you can see, this is our fee to serve balcony,
dams, And then there's the living area?
Kitchen. I think they recently had a party in here.
[Inaudible].
Anyways, I got to go wake up my friends cause uh,
I kind of want to go skiing early. Let's go.
No problem.
Butter jellies. How much?
I think I forgot your question or something. Cause like
I'm basically on call.
I'm just going to stay.
I still have to answer an email. Really?
[
inaudible]. Why did I go.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. What are you doing? I just got, I just got a text.
I have to do something real quick, dude. We're in the middle of a run chart.
I'll take only a second. It's so slow.
Are you serious? Shady to hotspot. Holy.
Just imagine I told you man, should I stay at home? Holy.
This is absurd. Yeah. Does your manager know you're in Tahoe?
Uh. Well, he knows I'm working from home,
but yeah, from home. Oh VPN. God.
[inaudible] Holy. How am I supposed to? This is so weird.
I was supposed to type on this. Oh my got it. This was
for you a kiss. Oh awesome. Thank you so much. You're the best.
I've never had a kiss before in my life.
My hands are so cold thing and also the clairs are really hard to see.
I'm so stressed bro. I so stressed. at my keyboard.
[inaudible] can we get like for debt, but for one part of it, it's good.
We're just waiting on the other part now. All right. Anyways,
we're going to go back to skiing later,
but right now we're just going to do that.
So I'm going to skip all this part pace. See you later.
What are you doing now? Better reception here.
Reception is a lot better. I can actually hotspot. Yeah.
I still have to answer this real quick. I haven't done it.
My hands are so cold. There's just something about the laptop. No worries.
Gotta do what you gotta do to make your, make your PM. Happy.
Try my best to stay alive.
Right? Look who is using my laptop right now.
What are you doing right now? Trying to get this quarter. Did you laugh at me?
When I brought my laptop? That's good. Foresight. See you owe me one. Now, dude,
you didn't even bring your own laptop. Now his manager is up on his.
So now he's working. There you go. See, I think I had, you know,
you laughed now. Like you've laughed before, but there you go.
I'm actually I ended up being right. All right. Once in awhile.
Meanwhile, back at home, we see software engineers in their natural habitat.
Working really hard to produce their quality code.
The laziest of the pack decided to bake cookies.
I was quickly denied of that luxury.
Darn it not again.
Good morning was popping up for breakfast.
What the? This is. Should we have combo jelly and eggs? Isn't that?
Normal
yellow brothers.
Jesse is so bored. He's.
Having fun, Jesse. So how big are you?
Wow.
What's popping. Look at this beautiful view. My God. I'm my friend Cyrus again.
How are you doing? Uh, yeah, today's a lot more chill cause it's Saturday.
So I definitely did not need to work today.
So that's why I don't have a backpack. I don't have my laptop, but then again,
my laptop is broken, so I can't work anyways, but Holy.
My laptop. What the?
Absolutely beautiful. But yeah,
I guess I'm going to say I might as well say it now. So as you know,
I said last time that was going to give a giveaway at 2,500, um,
subscribers, 5,000 and 10,020 5,000. And I miss all of those.
So that's why I am doing four giveaways. Woo. Get excited.
Unfortunately not AirPods this time. I can't afford AirPods anymore,
but I'm going to do a free giveaway for my merch.
So that means I'm going to pick four winners and I'm going to give you the
detailed later. Probably like not now, cause I can't think of anything,
but it's probably going to be following me on Instagram.
Follow me on Twitter and then write a question for me and the best questions
we'll get you free merch and what else?
And then I'll also like send me a video of a, a gentleman parody water.
If you want to buy him water. He was my sponsor code porn,
hub.com/jumo tech, Hey gentlemen,
parody or something like that. And the best one we'll also get free Marsh.
But yeah.
So I'll give you probably like a coupon and if you buy any one of the Birch, uh,
I'm going to try to design more of them. But I think so far,
just like a few of them and are pretty cool. But yeah. Yeah. Show me, show me,
show me that. Show me that one 80 bro. Whoo, barely 90.
No, that was not past night. All right. So I am uh,
teaching sunlight. How to snowboard. I am a great teacher.
I want to prove to the world what a great teacher I am.
What do you have to say?
Crappy all the time.
But it's not because I suck at TJ because she's.
No.
No. I want to show the world what a great teacher I am. So you better not up.
Excellent. Excellent. And then you break. Don't be afraid.
Cause I think it's all mental. How's it feel?
How's your first time snowboarding tire. Okay. That's good.
It means you're using egg, like your leg.
All right. Get up, get up, get up.
No wonder why your butt's so flat.
There you go. Stop being sideways. Go straight.
I, I missed it. I missed it.
I actually, I didn't film your face plant. So you're lucky.
Well, we got down the first floor. Yeah. Well the house let's go faster.
Ah, ah.
Can you start doing that? And just like, like, Oh no, like yeah,
like don't move your thing.
Don't don't break. Just, just stay until, until you're too afraid.
Like now's a good time to start like this.
Woo. That was good. That was good.
Really excited. Nice blogging skills gain. Really good.
There you go.
All right. So yeah,
I was just going to take a food break and here's three winners,
not as good as Facebook food, but you know, what can you do?
We can do this cost like 45 bucks. I think it's like 15 bucks.
Sausage sucks. So expensive. And like water's probably 10 bucks.
Oh, what a beautiful day. Look at the beautiful blue sky and a sun.
Me trying to get up for like 25 minutes. Oh my gosh.
Every run takes like 30 minutes.
It's because you're too lazy to unstrap because sun me is actually doing really
well right now.
I think I'm just going to blog a little bit and talk about my life. Um, yeah.
So what, what, what kind of topics should I talk about? Okay.
A lot of the questions I hear,
I hear about like what coding language or what kind of,
what kind of area you should focus on. But at the end,
I think quarterly language don't matter. It's all about fundamentals.
It's all about fundamentals. So like for example, coding, right?
Like in my mind, PHP C plus plus whatever,
if you write normal code or whatever you have in like those coding questions,
it's always so simple. It's always any like loops four loops,
four loops and stuff like that.
And a lot of people ask me what language is learned,
but that doesn't really matter because it's better to learn the,
like the fundamentals and the algorithms and just understanding how to build
products.
And then the reason why you would choose a language is either already libraries
or already frameworks or because you're working for a company that's using that
language anyways.
And then that's where you would maybe learn a little bit more language.
But most of the big companies, they don't, they don't even care.
[Inaudible] Hey, what's coffin. I'm Joe man. We're done for the weekend.
Thank you Jennifer, for the intro now. Thank you so much.
I'll don't forget if you liked this video,
don't forget to subscribe and also like the video and also follow me on
Instagram. Turn off the music. Holy, man.
I don't want a copyright strike anyways. Yeah. So as I said, you know,
hopefully like this blog,
if you'd like it more comment and then I'll probably do more,
but hopefully that was fun. You get to see what I do during the weekend. Uh,
that's usually not why I do join the weekend, but you know, it's my,
it's a highlight. It's a highlight. So yeah. Peace out. Um, uh,
maybe I shouldn't say that. Alright. Peace out.
Chad's not because it's kind of weird too. Okay. By ordinary viewers,
peace up.
[Inaudible].
That was really good.
It's really good.